what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so getting into edge of venom verse
this is actually a really cool concept
now edge your venom verse is actually
based on edge of spider-verse and that
was a story written by Dan Slott which
led into the spider verse story and
while Marvel does list this as a
five-part series if they're all
basically one shot you could read each
one of them individually now in truth
it's like reading any crossover event
right I mean like you could read edit
vanna verse you know each story by
itself or you could read issues to an
end if you read issue 5 and then never
read the other three but it's better
when it's all read together and the
reason why is because despite them being
one shot they do tell a cohesive story
that leads into venom verse proper edge
of spider-verse dealt with the idea of
just these alternate reality versions of
Spider Man that's actually where
spider-gwen came from she was just
basically from a reality where Gwen
Stacy was been by a radioactive spider
instead of Peter Parker there was
another universe where Peter Parker was
bitten by a radioactive spider and
became an actual spider and started
killing people there are some really
cool things that went on with those
different one shots and the different
variations of characters that we were
used to but this one deals with the idea
of x-23 becoming venom now the reason
why I titled it all new wolverine are
really you know just really wolverine in
general is because of the fact that it's
really easy to digest that way there are
more people that recognize the name
all-new wolverine as opposed to x-23 but
the fact remains the cool bit about this
is that this really kind of harkens back
to the origin story of Laura Kenney of
x-23 which you'll find down in the
description now with a story called
innocence loss but this basically deals
with the facility now one thing to keep
in mind here is that because this is
based on the origin of x-23 and because
she's currently only Wolverine really it
just kind of picks up from there and it
doesn't give us a lot of that backstory
and it really doesn't need to again this
really just kind of focuses on her
escape from the facility the fact that
she did it or at least you tried to
escape for other times and failed each
time in each instance she was basically
subdued with a gasp of source a more or
less knocked her out now again the
reason why we don't really need this and
to kind of go back to this origin story
a little bit because for the first
timers that are new to this I want to
leave you guys hangin x-23 was basically
a female genetic clone of Wolverine she
was female because of the fact that the
DNA of Wolverine had degraded to such a
degree that they couldn't make a perfect
male clone and so they made it
well instead and so what ended up
happening is x-23 was basically raised
to become an assassin she was still on
missions and she was very prodigiously
verb ility to take out any number of
people dignitaries political officials
different things like that average men
and women but she was also raised by a
woman named Sarah Kenney a believer was
and Sarah Kenney was the person that
actually gave birth to x-23 in order to
allow her to become an assassin and so
on but where the facility trained Laura
to be a killer Sarah tried to counteract
that by teaching her humanity by trying
to help her become a human being now of
course it didn't work right off the bat
she had been so mistreated and really
been stripped of her humanity on such a
deep level that even after her escaped
from the facility she basically you know
her stories went on to see her kind of
trying to regain her humanity getting
back in touch with over n different
things like that but this again really
hits home at that the difference here is
that Sarah is nowhere to be found in the
story but so the implication here is
that perhaps the cloning process was
successful and so far as they didn't
need Sarah Kinney and instead she was
basically grown in a tube and then
became a killer but the overall gist is
the same Laura does not want to be an
assassin she does not want to be
confined to this life of being made to
kill time and time again and so what is
up happening is in the middle of all
this was entire scenario she actually
ends up coming across the Venom symbiote
now again this is an alternate reality
story and so the things that basically
play out entirely different from what
we're used to the reason why I say that
is because of the fact that originally
in Marvel Comics the Venom symbiote was
actually an alien life-form that was
picked up by Peter Parker during the
events of the first Secret Wars back in
1984 1985 and it basically allowed
Marvel to move his character forward by
endowing him with a multitude of new
abilities now of course those stories
basically unfolded with Peter Parker
realizing that the costume that he was
wearing was sentient it did have a mind
of its own
and it led him down a much darker of
half and of course after Peter Parker
cast the symbiote aside it eventually
bonded to Eddie Brock and became venom
the character that were so familiar with
but the overall idea here is that
because this is a different reality we
don't know where this Venom symbiote
came from we don't know if it was
biologically engineered if it was
created by the facility we don't really
know where it came from all we know is
that where x-23 is trying to get away
from these guards in the facility she
ultimately ends up puncturing this tube
and is basically bonded with the
after which she just starts wrecking all
these different soldiers basically
killing them all off now at this point
we actually jumped forward by a couple
months got 2x20 threes first original
introduction into Marvel Comics just by
way of some of the characters like zebra
daddy for example and we'll get into him
here in a second but one thing I want to
point out here is back when x-23 was
originally created if she was more or
less made by Craig Kyle and Chris Yost
and she really made her debut and x-men
evolution but because she was so popular
Marvel eventually rolled her over into
Marvel Comics but they didn't
necessarily do this with the origin
story innocence lost instead what they
did is they created or at least tied her
into an existing story called NYX and
NYX dealt with the first again comic
book appearance of x-23 and it was the
idea that Laura was basically living as
an underaged prostitute in New York and
she was working for a guy named zebra
daddy of course NYX in and of itself was
a pretty adult oriented comic I mean it
wasn't anything fortuitous Marvel still
has a measure of propriety it's not like
Punisher match with the slavers story
which is absolutely insane but the
factory maimed here the character of
zebra daddy teenagers who were kind of
cast away that's all basically rooted in
the original NYX story the whole idea of
those characters is that they were
basically at least x-23 was essentially
a mutant living in New York City trying
to make her way and a lot of the kids
who were cast offs a lot of the kids who
didn't really have a home for themselves
they made their way on the streets doing
whatever was they needed to do to
survive and in this instance it actually
takes up with three kids who end up
going into this derelict Bank now the
other half of this is that it very much
draws on the existing concept of venom
in Marvel Comics and the reason why I
say that is because as far as I'm aware
historically speaking venom wasn't
really an entity that spoke directly
with its host instead the host would say
things like we or us and it would speak
as if there were multiple personalities
in there it would basically reference
both itself and the host that the
symbiote was bonded to but for the most
part I'm not really aware of an instance
when the symbiote would speak directly
to its host that may very well be
something that was there I mean I
wouldn't say I'm the most wildly
knowledgeable person when it comes to
venom that's really more of a question
for like solid comic pop to be honest
but the fact remains that in this
instance the familiarity of the Venom
symbiote talking to its house is rolled
over in the sense that when these kids
show up inside of this building the
bitters aviod initially wants to kill
him and it actually wants to consume
them it wants to eat them
which is kind of messed up but it's also
sort of interesting because x-23
basically runs them off now again this
is all rooted in the origin of x-23 and
the origin of law retaining the fact
that she's not really human the fact
that she you know doesn't really have
that human element that allows her to
develop social skills instead she
basically views the Symbian as the only
real thing that she needs but the other
half of this is that much like the
actual main Marvel comic stories she
yearns to basically have human contact
she wants to have a family of sorts or
at the very least she wants to have
friends and so what is up happening here
is where she and the Venom symbiote kind
of go back and forth over whether or not
these kids should be killed they
ultimately end up taking off due to the
fact that they think that x-23 is
essentially running them out where they
end up running into zebra Daddy now
again zebra daddy of course being the
pimp from NYX the guy who was basically
running the show with regards to x-23
and the idea here is that these kids
just owe him money now I mean this is
not wildly important it's not a great
big huge talking point what is up
happening with zebra daddy is kind of
important but for the most part it
really just allows the common ground it
allows the instance for x-23 to sort of
just pop up and then kill one of the
hired thugs of zebra daddy and in turn
save these kids now of course that's
exactly what happens and she just kind
of rips all these guys up
but then again we jump back to the idea
of the facility now remember we're not
given any names here so we don't know
this is Xander rice the guy from the
original x-23 origin story innocence
lost who was one of the people that
spearheaded the cloning process of her
in the first place and so again we're
just kind of told facility people are
looking for x-23
and by extension the venom Samia it
basically says anybody that you come
across and anybody that you make friends
with is going to be in mortal danger
because the facility will do whatever
they have to and kill whoever they have
to in order to get you back also
remember if the facility in this story
this alternate reality story is anything
like the facility in the main Marvel
Universe then it's basically the idea
that there can be no witnesses nobody
can be aware of what it is that they're
doing so that really creates even more
of an incentive for the facility to kill
these various kids but so something that
I hope you notice here is if this
actually gives us a reason to see these
individuals pair together if for no
reason other than the fact the next 23
serves as their protector of sorts and
this really comes to a head a few weeks
after zebra daddy basically points the
finger at x-23 says that's the girl that
attacked me and is killed by the
facility member when we end up finding
out that x-23 essentially serves as both
protector as well as a helping hand with
regards to these kids and so what she
actually does is just basically distract
a guide an ice-cream truck and one of
the kids punches her in the nose she
goes walking up to the guy in the ice
cream truck says look I'm bleeding all
over the place can you help me out a
couple of the kids grab boxes and they
take off but again in this particular
instance the facility is always watching
the facility is always aware of what's
going on because remember while the
facility is in and of itself a private
entity which is to say it's not beholden
to any governmental institution it does
have ties to various governments and so
it means that it does have the ability
to have eyes and ears all throughout
virtually any city this is also combined
with the fact that rumor is going to
spread and eventually stores are going
to spread about some person you know
that looks kind of crazy and it's
dressed in black and has claws it's
basically ripping things up in you know
downtown New York if anybody comes too
close to their turf and so really just
by kind of putting their their ear to
the ground and listening to the rumors
and so on and so forth it was only a
matter of time before they caught up
with x-23 but the cool thing about this
is that because law reviews these kids
as her friends this sim biet by
extension protects them as well as to
what this means is that these kids have
basically been given a Venom symbiote of
their own now it's not full-on right
like I'm a it's not a full-on Venom
symbiote it's just a small little
portion of the symbiote itself and so it
allows them to basically escape whatever
particular situation they're in but
they're not nearly as powerful or as
capable as x-23 now the other half of
this is how easy it is for a person to
get carried away with the venom Samiha
and that really goes back to Brian
Michael Bendis story and guardians of
the galaxy they gave us the whole origin
of the symbionts and the planet of the
symbiote story all I kind of get stuff
you know and the whole idea of Lee price
I think it is with regards to Marvel now
2.0 the Venom's a six part venom story
that we got before the legacy
remembering that saw it jump up to issue
number 150 and the return of Eddie Brock
the idea that the Venom symbiote is
again very sentient it has its own mind
it has its own desires and were the
Venom symbiote so far in Marvel Comics
and Marvel now as part of all-new
all-different marvel
had look to basically make itself a good
guy head look to you know essentially
make up for its past misdeeds what it
was bonded to Eddie Brock in this
universe that does not seem to be the
case instead the venom Samiha just wants
to destroy stuff this just wants to eat
people you know and just be a bad guy
now of course with the various agents of
the facility eventually tracking these
kids
down taking them prisoners are able to
use their aspects of the Venom symbiote
to fight off the members of the facility
of course it also sees the arrival of
x-23 but something else that I also hope
you notice here is that over the course
of this story the more that Laura's
begun to bond with the symbiote the more
that she becomes essentially like a
symbiote version of Wolverine and so
again it's kind of cool because her
physical appearance begins to change she
begins to dawn yellow more so than she
did before she gets the large eyes she
gets the face thing that black face
thing I don't know how to describe it I
guess a mask of sorts you know she
basically becomes this minimized version
of Wolverine that we're so familiar with
in in Marvel Comics and so following
this it's really just kind of tearing up
these different members of the of the
facility of these different soldiers of
course fire is still very much a
weakness of the symbiote and so if we're
one of these guys you use the
flamethrower and ultimately lower is
able to make a last-second escape into
this sort of holding room
what is up happening is that the venoms
to me it actually recalls this smaller
aspects from these other kids and
directly into Laura after which it's
whisked away into a void of source now
we don't really know what's going on
with this I mean again this will
probably be covered in some other set of
events or something along those lines
maybe will be continued in parts two
three four and five
but Laura Kinney basically comes back
almost immediately after she advantaged
and of course the question is well what
happened to her friends where they go to
somebody take them so on and so forth
but before any of the questions can
actually be answered she's met by the
arrival of a venom eyes diversion of
Captain America so again it's a really
cool concept
it's a really cool idea here and I
really like the way this is going
because it's extremely good so it's a
really cool really cool concept but with
that being said guys we're going to go
ahead and bring this video to an end if
you are new here to comics explained
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the robb core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
please
[Music]